this is lucy james reading for reviewer
heidi kemps one of the most recognizable
characteristics of a jrpg is the party a
ragtag group of adventurers from
different walks of life who unite their
strengths for a common cause almost
always under the leadership of a
designated main character while the rest
of the cast may wind up getting side
quests and story arcs the majority of
the game revolves around a specific
character it's a trope that's as common
as they come but all the way back in
1994 square now square enix released
live alive in japan turning the genre on
its head by asking what if a jrpg had
several main characters and they all had
a fully realized plotline different
worlds and distinct gameplay gimmicks it
was a unique game well ahead of its time
but sadly one confined to japan for
decades with no official english release
that changes with this modern remake and
amazingly live alive not only holds up
well but manages to feel unique
compelling and excitingly original even
when compared to its modern
contemporaries
[Music]
live alive's protagonists come from many
different places across space and time
ranging from the cartoony prehistoric
world of caveman pogo to the modern day
championship struggles of mixed martial
arts fighter masaru all the way to a
far-flung future where tiny robot cube
awakens on a mysterious cargo transport
ship these seven divergent chapters can
be completed in any order and you can
stop one chapter to pick up another as
you please finishing these chapters
unlocks an eighth story which leads into
a final chapter where all the paths
converge into one last epic struggle
what makes live alive unique beyond its
multiple protagonists is how
dramatically gameplay elements change
from chapter to chapter
the martial arts master earthen heart
shifu doesn't gain levels himself but
instead focuses on strengthening his
disciples by fighting with and alongside
them the wild west outlaw sundown kid
can make things significantly easier or
much harder for himself by helping a
village prepare to battle a savage gang
of invading bandits cube's interstellar
horror story has almost no required
fighting at all while masaru's
championship road is nothing but a
string of rapid-fire battles even the
chapters with more typical rpg
progression offer unique twists the huge
maze dungeon that ninja aburumaru must
stealthily navigate and psychic youth
akira's mind-reading ability give their
respective stories distinct delightful
quirks all of them have one thing in
common however the existence of a
similarly named malevolent force
you've kept me waiting long enough
speak each main chapter lasts between
one to five hours making sure no mini
adventure overstays its welcome and
every outing looks and sounds great too
it can't be understated just how good
live alive's presentation is square enix
put a lot of care and love into remaking
this game and it shows the graphics use
the company's fan favorite hd 2d engine
seen in games like octopath traveler and
triangle strategy to create gorgeous
vibrant environments that retain a retro
rpg feel the character sprites
themselves are beautifully detailed and
brimming with personality perhaps best
exemplified in the pre-history chapter
where a lack of dialogue makes their
expressiveness all the more vital to the
storytelling accompanying the visuals is
a fantastic soundtrack
[Music]
live alive is one of famed composer yoko
shimamura's earliest contributions to
square enix delivering a variety of
musical styles to accompany the many
different adventures the original 16-bit
songs have been fully re-recorded with
high-quality instruments and sometimes
even song lyrics making them sound even
more bombastic additionally all of the
game's key story dialogue is voice acted
helping bring the main characters to
life and adding extra flair to some of
the strange and shocking twists the
narrative can take damn it
one of the key commonalities across all
the live alive's chapters is its
turn-based combat system which features
ideas just as unique as the other parts
of the game fights happen on a grid of
7x7 squares which characters can move
upon freely when it's their turn to act
there's no ap mp system restricting
skill usage instead both player and
enemy attacks have specified ranges and
charge times before they activate this
adds a new layer of strategy to battles
making positioning and observing enemy
and player action time crucial to
success while offering a refreshing
degree of freedom
[Music]
element-like skills that create damage
tiles leader enemies that end the battle
when defeated and accessory gear that
can be used as supporting items in
battle provide even more options and
variety to the clever player combat does
have its issues however there's no way
to skip or speed up these sometimes
lengthy attack animations and it can be
difficult at times to determine your
charge attack time relative to that of
the enemy leading to frustrating
interrupted attacks in my time playing i
must have suffered six or seven enemy
interruptions for every one time i was
able to stop theirs sudden difficulty
increases are also common although
usually grinding up a level or two which
doesn't take too long will help you
power through tough barriers still it
would have been nice if there were
combat tweaks to keep battles from
dragging damn it you did well for mere
mortal going up against the gods chosen
and while live alive has done a
spectacular job in updating its
presentation and adding numerous small
quality of life upgrades over the snares
original there are a handful of
frustrating old-fashioned gameplay ideas
that would likely get vetoed if
developers tried to include them in a
modern game things like having to farm a
random enemy encounter to get keys
needed to progress in a dungeon yes or
no dialogue choices that can lead to an
instant game over if you choose
incorrectly a mad scientist who can
sometimes upgrade any item you give him
but only occasionally and only after a
bunch of repetitive dialogue you'll see
over and over until he succeeds among
others the lack of a proper detailed
minimap while understandable in some
chapters proves frustrating in others
even the steps necessary in the final
chapter to get to the true last boss and
ending aren't made entirely clear
leaving you with an unsatisfying
conclusion unless you either look up an
faq or somehow manage to find all the
factors you need on your own these
issues don't ruin the experience of live
alive by any means but they can feel a
bit blindsiding to those used to more
modern jrpg features that aid a player's
understanding when it comes to
progression and makes the experience
more approachable remember this moment
save the memory if you take my meaning
in case it all goes sideways
i truly loved my experience playing live
alive the gameplay and narrative variety
incredible visuals and superb soundtrack
kept me enthralled throughout my 30-hour
journey i still feel like the game has a
few secrets and little story bits i may
have overlooked it's quite the
accomplishment that almost 30 years
later live alive still manages to
surprise subvert and enthrall those
timeless qualities make it well worth
your attention now and likely for years
to come
so
[Music]
you